I like the wide-angle oh come on Hank
yeah this is courtesy of Mitchell Davis
I saw it in the videos like years ago
and I was like I want your exact setup
well I'm obsessive Mitchell Davis yeah
we're kinda so creative Mitchell this is
for you mm-hmm eat [ __ ] haha hi guys I'm
here at Connor Franta
I think we've ever made a video today we
have around each other but we've never
clap until today right now I thought
what else is happening at one
it's almost Conor's birthday it is
that's exciting and has nothing to do
with this video you know what else is
happening right around now school I've
got enough for us high five to that
alternative career fairs all day in
school actually yeah I think it's a
great idea I mean you did it
Hey two years credits are still there
and I got through high school so Hey
good great all right thinking those two
letters of the alphabet guys this could
be all yours
yeah how dare you discount upwards of $5
one of the things that happens in school
sometime is maybe doesn't for you and
maybe it does our superlative for some
reason is in high school mostly we like
to rank each other I went on Twitter and
asked you guys to send me some weird
superlatives and we are going to choose
youtubers that we think are the most
appropriate for those with relatives
when I get off rhythm rank it our friend
hey Marie maybe you can be the judge and
like decide who got the better
superlative you don't have to explain
why we think the person I love maybe
loves to do through will get over it
okay well write them all down first then
we'll go back through for memory most
likely to have their nudes leaked
most likely to teach a sex ed class
there is a youtuber that does this I
don't know her I do
Oh best forehead
these are things I don't think about
exactly don't touch me most likely to
spill mashed potatoes on themselves in a
public venue we were heading blacks
yesterday for lunch
actually lunches but most likely to
sharped by immediate and they'll see
myself out who would actually allow
themselves to feel that uncomfortable in
a place to allow that to happen
move is having too much who's that makes
too much about that who makes good jokes
besides myself like every video she's
sitting directly to your left
what's up I'm wearing my visibility
cloak we're thinking so deeply about
shirts right now most likely to dance at
a party by themselves most likely to be
hungover at an important meeting just
chill your answers fine I guarantee
their goal what was likely to lose their
phone while talking to someone on the
phone best black pair already please
last one most likely to be their own
form double is incredible
most likely to have their nudes leaked
rickey dillion I said Sawyer Hartman Oh
mein rehne who you give us no soy yeah
most likely to teach a sex ed class
appetizer ugly
I would tell it first I also have Laci
green is that her name yeah then I give
it to you a hundred percent Laci green
actually does really great what best
4head i said Hannah Hart
I said Miranda sings Oh Hannah Hart's
got back but a description for this one
I was gonna say myself cuz I got my bump
oh what's above room I felt my bed is
like an eight-year-old and hit my head
against a dresser why not I'm going to
cry oh yeah okay Miranda get down get
down
go say hi to your uncle most likely to
spill mashed potatoes on themselves in a
public venue Connor Franta is what I
said I would almost agree but I have a
choice Avadh because I've seen him spill
a glass of wine on someone's white couch
before his arms are so unreliable I see
and Troy eat point Economo slightly too
sharp after deep consideration yes it is
I said Mary Hart I was like instinct but
I tried to really think about it because
I think may rain has come so close to
sharding so many times that she knows
that she can like handle it
um I put Toby Turner because I just feel
like that guy's all over the place I
feel like he shortens or like throwing
it on the clean shirt and it turned into
a daily blog before my own ego for grace
yeah oh you know who we should put
Louise oh my god actually points to
someone else Louise I'm most likely to
dance at a party by themselves I put
Flula I put Hannah Hart oh now in
hindsight
I put Michael Buckley actually first
hand seen him dance at a party by
himself - we can't stop ah Lula was
right across from me at the streamys
last night and he was just getting it
all by himself so yeah I feel like I'm
gonna have to give it to you what about
the judge judgment what to my dear dear
Luna yeah I was lucky to be hung over at
an important meeting I said most likely
to lose their phone while talking to
someone on the phone I put myself did
you for myself for some reason I thought
I thought Lea Marie Johnson would be
that you'd be talking to JC on the phone
because he lost my phone Thank You
Edmund phone anywhere but I know I did
that the other day so that's why from
Judge memory Congress phone do work
while we Instagram point to come here
best class I had to put Tyler Oakley
again he's got a great labs you know who
else has the moon does I know I'm
missing somebody Harley Morenstein yeah
more it sounds like it's coming from
like a ten year old girl getting tickled
I think we know we'll go to the judge
just in case she's feeling very generous
to make it a tie game not talk to me
yeah last one we're tied most likely to
be their own porn double did you put
Miranda sings because she would not be
in porn with any of the presents I just
thought the person that I know that
takes the most selfies and that is Ricky
Dillon oh he takes the most up he knows
he does he owns up to taking the most
selfies so Miranda would be her own porn
and her own foreign co-star and the
director the director why didn't God
Bluetooth realize you one on your own
channel yeah it doesn't feel really
weird and self-serving when you win a
contest that you brought up on your own
channel guys go over and subscribe to
cata fridge it cuz he's just a lovely
human being and go over and watch
Reuters ever drink because maybe made a
drink for Connor or a certain day super
it's delicious it's delicious a junk
junk check it out
I don't know hello guys I forgot to
mention or I wanted to mention that the
no filter show the may marine Hannah and
I do our live comedy show is going back
on tour in October ah my book comes out
in October so this tour will be a
motional tour for my book races guide
the art of pretending to be a grown-up
which if you haven't pre-ordered it
enter the sweepstakes yet please do
Grace's guide book calm there are over
600 prizes that we're giving away and
we're giving away 10 signed bookmarks
each week before the contest officially
on so please do that anyway the tour is
happening we're going to hold on let me
make sure I have all the correct
information for you guys okay we're
kicking it off in Chicago which is so
exciting because we've never been to
Chicago before and I've always wanted to
go to do the show there I've only been
once and unfortunately my body can't
handle pizza fun we're also going to the
Bell house in Brooklyn we're going to be
playing a show in Manhattan we're gonna
be playing oh we're playing a show on
Halloween in Minneapolis I don't know
where that is
can't wait and then we are wrapping up
the tour in Denver so please all the
links for tickets are down below
get them ASAP because we're playing um
bling venues where tickets will
inevitably sell out so get yours as soon
as you can October yay no bill to show
Lisa's guidebook DICOM no whistle oh
yeah you might warms up and I guess it
wait oh but we're working on it
someone looped that with his lap